all right people welcome to the Rubin
report post democratic debate wrap-up
show it's not quite post wrap up I just
couldn't take it anymore
I was trying to watch that thing and I
actually felt that I might have been
getting brain damage in the middle of it
it's just such boring drivel from a
bunch of people who seemingly can't
smile or find anything to be proud of
about this country or or find any joy in
any of this and it's just uh I couldn't
take it so you know what I've got whisky
you know what I had here I had one of
those awesome
you know those huge ball ice cubes that
you can make we made me a giant
beautiful ball ice cube but it cracked
the second we put it in here but I've
got whisky
I've got your questions on a trusty iPad
and we're gonna talk about the debate
we've got video clips and I promise you
I promise you if you're watching this
right now you are gonna get more joy and
information out of this thing then you
will on any wrap-up show on CNN or MSNBC
or what ABC is gonna do or the rest of
it it's just all so stiff I mean you can
watch CNN instead of this you know when
they go live in a few minutes and you
can just watch ten people sitting at a
desk all who got everything wrong four
years ago you can watch them get
everything wrong again or you can watch
Dave with a little whiskey and an iPad
so yeah we took in we ingest it as they
say in the business a bunch of video
clips so we'll play some clips some of
the highlights and lowlights although
there weren't many highlights I don't
think and then we'll take your questions
so we are taking questions for
subscribers only at Rubin report.com so
you can still jump in I've got a live
Google Doc right here so they'll send
them to me right here at Rubin report
com or you can download the group and
report app in the Apple App Store or on
Google Play I'll take your questions and
all that good stuff
I thought first what I should do is well
first off what are you guys drinking I'm
curious to know but I will take a little
whiskey that's nice I think that's
Johnnie Walker Black Label if I'm not
mistaken we're doing all right around
here I guess first I'll just tell you a
little bit share some of my thoughts on
the whole thing
I mean in case you can't tell I'm just
not impressed by this group of people I
mean you guys know how I feel about
Burnie at the end of the day look Burnie
is just an old socialist sort of at the
end right it's this endless I can do
everything everybody was parable before
me and I could do it I'm gonna do it
it's just it's it's it's Larry David
with no sense of humor if you threw
another ten years on him and it's just
not there he his answer to everything is
government period has Bernie done a
couple decent things over the years yes
he did not vote for the Iraq war so that
was good right and he's very proud of
that and that actually is good he had
the foresight not to do it not to trust
George W Bush which he made a point
actually tonight to say Biden well you
voted for it and Biden was like well I
trust you George W Bush and bi and
Bernie was like well you know bad move I
didn't trust him so yeah I'll give
Bernie credit where credit's due but
he's been in the Senate for you know
about thirty years he's never really
accomplished anything no major piece of
legislation has ever had his name on it
he's never really worked with anyone
across the aisle he's done nothing yeah
he's a millionaire he's become a
millionaire that's pretty good and he's
got three houses and that's pretty great
but I think you know my feelings about
Bernie Sanders and I'm sure there'll be
some questions there and he's the one
that really has radicalized the left
into thinking that socialism is somehow
good and that the government should just
do everything so whether we get hung up
on the word socialist or not in essence
what they're always talking about now is
that these people that somehow Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders and Tom Steyer
and Pete Budaj edge can somehow run your
life better than you can and I just
simply don't believe it I if one of them
would just get on stage and be like hey
I can't fix your life I got my own
problems I just want to stay out of your
life keep more of your money live live
freely you know you got my vote
that's the guy I wanted both or the guy
I want to vote for do you guys see the
movie Brewster's Millions
it's a Richard Pryor movie from about
1990s 1988 or so where he plays Brewster
this guy who is a Hackensack Bulls he's
a pitcher for a minor league baseball
team called the Hackensack Bulls and he
finds out he has a distant relative who
says to him if you spend thirty million
dollars in a month I'll give you the
real
inheritance which is 300 million dollars
and Brewster has to spend all this money
so what does he do he becomes a
politician to waste money and at the end
here his whole campaign is anyway is it
anyone but me can one of you guys google
it what's Brewster Millions what's his
campaign slogan vote for anyone but me
or none of the above that's what it is
none of the above and it's like that's
what I'm looking for out there these
people are just not impressive all right
so that's Bernie look Biden man Biden
it's it's it's sad I don't want to make
any glib comments about age or what's
going on seemingly with him mentally or
any of that he seemed like he struggles
to complete a thought struggles to
complete a sentence you know you've been
around people like this everyone's been
around people like this when you're
around your grandparents or some older
person who they start talking and you're
like oh can you finish that sentence you
get you feel this like weird thing with
them and Biden seems to be going into
that place also you know he keeps
harkening back when he can suddenly like
she'll go out of that he he keeps
harkening back to what I did with Obama
what I did with Obama what I did with
Obama except what he doesn't understand
is the base doesn't care about that the
base thinks that Obama was some sort of
evil corporatist Democrat centrist
Republican conservative or something
like that they think that you know Obama
Obama ran for president against gay
marriage remember that so I always say
this but it's like the press's of
tomorrow we're gonna hate the
progressives of today the progressives
of 2050 are gonna want to burn down the
Obama library which i think is being
built in Chicago right now because he
ran again he was against gay marriage
and in 2013 or 2012 whatever it is and
it's like when Biden keeps talking about
oh let's go back to Obama it's like
that's not what the base wants anymore
man like so Biden seemingly is done plus
all the Ukraine stuff and the whole
ridiculous impeachment thing makes Biden
look worse than it does Trump so that's
that so that's by it and that's Bernie
Elizabeth Warren I think is just done
too I mean all she has is that we're a
bunch of racists coming from a woman who
said she was Native American so she
could you know get get a gig at Harvard
she just she's so uninspiring she's like
a librarian that you would be afraid of
if you were in sixth grade can't smile
like there's just like no joy there she
just knows how to do everything
you know she's she wants you to send
your children into public school but her
children don't go to
public school of course she's a
millionaire and I don't mind
millionaires I would like to be a
millionaire that would be great but the
dis constant class warfare that they're
all playing I think she's just done like
she's just because why if you're gonna
do whatever it is she's doing it's like
yeah at that point you just go with
Bernie so so she's done amy klobuchar
strikes me as a decent human being
she's she's sort of like a sitcom mom
from like an 80s or 90s sitcom right
like she should have been married
Everybody Loves Raymond or something
like that but she strikes me as a decent
person you know it's interesting she
talks about how we can't sort of rip
down everything in the past and not
everyone used to be evil and that we
should work with other people on the
other side and the government shouldn't
be there for everything now is she too
big government for me probably is a lot
of it's just it's seemingly just like
endless talking into nothing but like
she strikes me as like does she love the
country yes does does she seem like she
genuinely would work with Republicans
and extend the arm honestly of course
you think any Republican is ever gonna
work with Bernie and you think Bernie
wants to work with any Republican no no
no no no and by the way that's not even
blaming one side more than the other I
mean both sides have become horrible at
that but we do need more people
hopefully that'll bounce back and forth
and be able to excuse me work with the
other side so Klobuchar Jack actually
just strikes me as somebody like she's
not embarrassed by America I think she's
confused on some of her policies but
seems like a decent lady
Tom Steyer it's not even worth talking
about he's a billionaire who bought his
way in
it's like [ __ ] all right you love
reparation so much you got you got a
couple billion how about how about five
hundred million tomorrow it's like show
me the money man you got you're telling
me and the rest of us who had nothing to
do with slavery no one in my family none
of my ancestors owned slaves and even if
they did eat generations and generations
and generations ago I'm not guilty by my
father's sins much less many many
generations ago but you got a couple
hundred million just that would be
pretty easy for you to dump out and I'm
sure you could figure out a way to to
write it off right just do it through a
non-profit it's a write-off but he
doesn't do it right because this is all
virtue signaling nonsense so Tom Styer
forget him who else we did what we got
yang is the last one I want to hit I
forgot no oh and boo to judge I mean boo
to judge it's like man how are you gonna
be the one sort of millennial or Gen X
ish type right so I'm 43 I think he's
can someone check the age
Budi judge I think he's probably about
38 something like that it's like he
comes off as if he's like a standard 64
year old politician just so stiff
there's so little sort of human in there
it's like why can't you talk like this
why cannot you be able to just
communicate in some sort of functioning
way he just he can't do it and and he
has that sort of deer in headlights look
where he's like I can't believe I'm even
doing this why am I doing this
and then there's yang who I think you
know I've had him in this room I think
the guy is a decent guy I think ubi is
kind of interesting not really my thing
because I just think it creates more
government bureaucracy it'll ultimately
cost goods and goods to go up in price
and things like that but like is he a
decent guy who has an interesting way of
looking at the world and it's sort of a
new a new voice in all of this yes you
know unfortunately the it ain't
happening for him but I think that least
he's a decent guy I should also mention
that tulsi gabbard should have been
there she's not there and she's actually
a Democrat that's a little more of sort
of like an old-school Blue Dog Democrat
who says where it's like you're not
gonna believe this cuz these aren't
words that any of these people are gonna
say she says where it's like freedom
scary scary words you know about
empowering you to live your life as you
see fit and not having the government do
everything for you she says those scary
words and she wants us out of Wars and
she actually thinks that there should be
limits on abortion even though she's
pro-choice and a series of other
interesting things that were once
moderate positions so you know
unfortunately the base the the
progressives who are really basically
socialists and that they should be
sitting at the children's table they've
just ransacked the whole party so for a
same voice and I say this all the time
but Biden they dragged his old bones out
because he was supposed to be the one to
be the same voice and the reason you
that it's obvious that they know it's
not working is why is Bloomberg running
now right like if if the Biden thing
made any sense and if they didn't think
it wasn't going to implode then then
Bloomberg would have no reason to run
because the Biden and Bloomberg have any
major real differences no of course not
but the Biden thing is just not working
and he's refusing to be
the adult in the room and the one that I
I think is the best example of this is
when they were at the LGBT equality
forum and Biden said it's not your
biological sex that should just
determine which jail you go to it's what
gender you say you are so it seems like
there would be a lot of male rapists in
female prisons right the next season of
orange is the new black is gonna be lit
alright so I want to get to your
questions we'll do a couple will do a
couple clips I got it Budaj edge is 38
years old I mean he's 38 going on 85
right it's like show a little human
there man come on dude all right so
let's go - you know what I'll take a
question and then we'll go to clips in
my opinion tulsi gabbard is the same as
choice that the Democrats could make
what will it take for the DNC to
actually support someone like her I mean
it ain't happened and this time I'll
tell you that much I think what has to
happen and here's this is my prediction
I've been predicting this for quite some
time this monster that we're all seeing
this identity politics monster the
socialist monster this this Bernie led
monster it's going to destroy the
Democratic Party I'm not saying that the
Democratic Party will not exist after
this election but it will be so
fractured that there really will be two
splinters of this so right now while the
Republican Party seems to be coming
together it actually seems to be a kind
of wide tent with conservatives and
libertarians and some old classical
liberals and there's a there's just like
an ability to agree to disagree
great example of this tucker carlson
who's a conservative who is now for
regulating big tech and someone like me
who's completely against it we could
still say we could sit in a room and not
kill each other at the end of it these
people seem unable to hash any of it out
with try it without trying to destroy
each other so I think what will happen
is the party will basically be destroyed
the progressives if Bernie doesn't win
they will bring violence to Milwaukee
for sure they're telling you that that's
what they're gonna do and that's really
what the base wants and you know when I
was at the Young Turks years ago not
that I had many deep political
conversations with anyone there off
camera or even on camera but Sir off
camera but there were times many times I
remember actually that some of the
people there would talk about how
they're for political violence that you
are you need some violence to make some
things happen
this is very much in what the
progressive ethos is and I think what
has to happen is the it's almost as if
they have to be so destroyed so that
maybe a phoenix can rise out of the
ashes and maybe a new democrat can be
born if that's if that's what you think
should happen because you want a healthy
democratic party and that's maybe a
party that could be more led by someone
like policy gaved but she will not I
look by the time the DNC is done with
her and by the time the DNC is done with
Yang and some of the other ones that are
somewhat interesting you know there's
there's a lot of opportunity for either
a new party to form there or the Clinton
machine died out and something you know
move and shift there so there's there's
interesting stuff that is possible do I
get a bonus for having to watch that
well in that I am my own boss I should
give myself some sort of bonus I guess I
got whisky that's pretty good
that's about it do you think all of this
is moot if Trump really does have 30
percent black support well I don't know
where you're coming up with 30 percent
although I did tweet that I truly think
Trump might get 30 percent black support
I know that sounds completely insane but
let's say it's it's only 20 percent and
it's that's like triple I think at least
what he got last time we could check the
numbers on that it might even maybe he
got like four percent I mean that would
be that would be five times what he got
black unemployment as is at an all-time
low he's doing criminal justice reform
these are real things you could even
feel it up there when they had that like
ten minute burst where they endlessly
talk about systemic racism and Bernie
what's the quote from Bernie do we have
the quote here I mean Bernie was just
that awful line about America has been
built on racism and it's like this is
the freest place nobody cares what race
you are
are there people individual people that
are racist yes are there individual
people that don't like gays and don't
like this and that yeah but you can come
here and do whatever you want that's why
everyone does come here and do it so man
yeah but the answer your question is yes
if Trump gets 30% of the black vote he's
gonna win this thing in a landslide I
suspect he's winning this thing in a
landslide no matter what I think the
impeachment thing was such a backfire
you've fired up all the base you took
all of the decent centrists who were
like this impeachment thing was nonsense
right after you ran with three years of
Russia and to me it's like I going to
win in a landslide
and we'll see no way around it at this
point certainly not with these guys I
don't know maybe they dragged Hillary's
old bones and then it's a little closer
alright one more and then I will throw
to some clips will you be taking phone
calls from relatives tonight while alive
that's a little shout-out to the other
night after State of the Union Larry
King for those either didn't see it he
was telling me a story about why he has
a flip phone he has an old-school flip
phone he doesn't text so one of my guys
brought it in to him while we were alive
and he and his phone rang that moment
and he took a call from his son it was
actually pretty pretty hilarious and
beautiful moment alright one more and
then then I'll throw to some clips so
we'll get to that how can we take
seriously any candidate who's telling us
that the economy is doing poorly you
know I was thinking something like that
during this because well it's all doom
and gloom everything that they say up
there there's nothing I didn't hear one
thing in an hour and a half the thing
could be still going on right now but I
didn't hear anything that was inspiring
right like like there's good things
happening and we can make better things
happening so if it is true that all that
black hole unemployment is at an
all-time low Latino unemployment an
all-time low all of the numbers that
Trump was talking about the other day
and we know the economy is super strong
right now we just know it is right we
know that right now we are not going to
more Awards remember World War 3 a month
ago when we killed Soleimani and
everyone said we're going to World War
three ya know World War three we just
restored some deterrence no World War
three we made it right to blip in
nothingness so you know it's like they
can't they sort of need reality to be
horrible otherwise they have no case to
be made and I think that's sort of why
they seemed so hysterical the reality of
the situation is things are actually
pretty good it's really hard to see if
you only listen to mainstream media but
but things are pretty good so all right
let's we've got a bunch of clips so
let's let's throw to some clips because
I'm sure that all of you did not watch
this thing but we want to get to some
clips here this is when Bernie calls
this is number one Bernie calls Trump a
liar and he says he's going to beat him
with voter turnout
here and before the Super Bowl he joked
with Sean Hannity about your honeymoon
in Moscow those hits are going to keep
coming if you're the nominee
why shouldn't democrats be worried
because
by having the largest voter turnout in
this country appealing to working-class
people who have given up on the
political process because they don't
believe that anybody is is hearing their
pain perceiving that pain feeling their
pain and we got to bring young people
into the political process I'm very
proud than in Iowa we won the popular
vote by six thousand votes what was most
significant most significant is we
increased voter turnout for young people
under twenty nine by over thirty percent
we do that naturally we're gonna defeat
yeah there's so much there first of
notice he didn't address anything that
Trump actually said which in essence is
are you a socialist he never really
denied being a socialist he is a
socialist and perhaps really a communist
right he wants the government to do
everything he literally wants the
government to be involved in whether
Major League Baseball should have minor
league teams I am not making that up
he's been talking about that like he
wants the government and absolutely
everything that in essence is communism
you know it's funny he also talked about
his record high voter turn up for young
people except overall the Iowa caucuses
the numbers were deeply deeply depressed
so it's not like people are that excited
about this crew also they couldn't even
figure out who won for days and it's
sort of like I will just say boo to
judge one but maybe Bernie one or Bernie
one but boo to judge one let's not who
really cares about any of that I think
in a way and there's a few questions
that ask something like this a few
people are asking something to the
effect of well wouldn't Bernie verse
trump be the best way that we end all of
this that we sort of had the ultimate
the rise of Skywalker
finale to this whole thing you know the
ultimate good versus battle socialism
versus capitalism fight in a weird way
that makes sense but my suspicion is the
DNC ain't gonna let it happen they're
deeply corrupt we know they're deeply
corrupt a handicap Bernie last time and
birdie by the way who was you know just
what do you say up there you know he's
ready to go down again because he's like
we got a beat that damn guy or whatever
it is and we're all gonna stand together
to do it and well alright so you mean
when they take you out you're gonna
support somebody again just like you did
to Hillary last time you know yeah I
mean the other thing the Bernie is that
identity politics will shred him one day
because no matter how much he tries to
play it at the end of the day he's just
an old white guy cuz guess what Bernie
even though you occasionally play half
Jew that doesn't matter that doesn't
count as a minority in that oppression
Olympics pyramid so he's an old white
guy that they'll they'll take out one
day and in a pretty horrific way let's
see let's go to some questions let's see
what's the ultimate outcome of this
clearly the Democrats have taken a wrong
turn I assume even their supporters are
having doubts I mean look I can tell you
this the amount of emails that I am
getting now over the last couple months
from people saying I've always voted
Democrat and I cannot do it for this
crew and that had a lot to do with
impeachment also is becoming
overwhelming we're getting a ton and ton
of mail now that's not a total it's not
a totally fair way of estimating
everything but I think I've had a pretty
good track record of being able to
figure out what the trends over the last
couple years and I just sent speed the
average person the average person likes
America the average person is proud of
America the average person doesn't think
America is racist the average person
doesn't think America is evil or was
founded on genocide or any of these
things and these guys refuse to say they
didn't but what what positive message
did they give up there but Biden is
angry up there right because Biden's
trying to defend something that he knows
is good but he knows it doesn't play in
that room so Biden you know there was a
really interesting moment with Biden in
the Constitution let me see real quick
if we have it as one of our clips I
don't think so actually
where Biden's talking about the
Constitution when they were talking
about abortion and it's like dude you're
in the wrong room man these people don't
care about the Constitution they don't
care what they want is what
they want the Constitution is just a is
just a roadmap sorry a road bump for
that so yeah it's it's screwy let's see
are you gonna be playing a drinking game
where every time the term 1% is said you
take a drink if so I bet the live
broadcast will be more entertaining and
worthy of spending a Friday night then
watching these pointless debates I will
take a drink or that they didn't say 1%
you know it's interesting they've moved
off the 1% thing if you've noticed they
say billionaires a lot now which is
interesting because you know it used to
be sort of millionaires than it was the
1 percent now it's billionaires and I
think partly why they moved off the 1
percent thing was the 1 percent thing
was always nonsense we could check the
numbers on this but some it's something
like if you're in the 1% if you make
something like 450 grand a year now
that's a lot of money right that's more
money than I make I'm guessing it's more
money than you guys make
but if 450 grand a year that you can you
have no ability to pull levers of power
or anything like that even with a couple
million dollars a year which any of us
would love to have you don't have any
real power so they kept saying 1 percent
and it's nonsense what they really mean
is like the point zero one percent like
the ultra ultra ultra ultra rich who by
the way I don't begrudge them being rich
right like every time nobody's ever
become a billionaire illegally or
without inheriting it or bought a lot
it's like oh you want to tell that to
Oprah I think she did okay how about
that Ellen DeGeneres or Warren Buffett
was he stealing money from everybody or
Bill Gates and the funny thing was with
these billionaires and you can really
feel it with Tom Steyer that fool
it's like he's so guilty over what he
created you know doing so he gets up
there and all he wants to do is like
jump around what was that little dog
remember in like the the Bugs Bunny
commercials Bugs Bunny cartoons way back
when there was that little was a little
dog that was always jumping around the
big dog and just wanted his attention
and Tom Styer is like that with Bernie
and Bernie's like yeah get out of it but
steyr it's just like stop being guilty
all these people Bill Gates he thinks
that if he gives away enough money they
won't come for him one day they won't
throw him in the pit of Sarlacc dude
it's coming for you no matter what
there's nothing you can do for these
people that's the thing all right let's
go here oh wait a minute we changed our
password on this thing hold on okay here
we go
what was the most impactful or
interesting moment of the night well I
guess the theme tonight was that it
seems to be that Budaj edge has like a
little momentum or something like that
so there definitely were more pointed
attacks on him and he has that that
starstruck look in his eyes you know
he's looking at the car he's like a deer
caught in the headlights kind of thing I
don't think he really wants this it
seems like it's like why would you want
this dude you're 38 years old you know
you seem like a decent guy he doesn't
have a real emotional range it's like be
just be a little bit more of human but
it was interesting watching and you see
this in all this happens every four
years Republican Democrat it doesn't
matter someone starts getting a little
momentum and then everyone starts coming
from them right because you got to take
them down and the way you're gonna get
the press to start following you is if
you give them the kill shot and it all
starts becoming a like an exaggerated
theater in essence so I think that was
interesting because it was the first
time he's had that I don't think he's
gonna hold that position for for very
for very long I didn't watch but let me
guess everyone is racist yeah I mean
there was a major moment the Bernie yet
we're all racist this whole place is
racist Tom Styer were all racist but
even Biden threw in some of it it's like
no again guys no and this doesn't work
for anybody anymore we're all sick of
being called racist you know like III
believe me I have traveled enough of
this country in the last two years and
met literally thousands and thousands of
people the same people that you guys
call racist all the time and I find them
to be not only not racist but I find
them very often to be minorities I find
them to be black and brown people and
Asian people and all of this other
nonsense so it's just not working
anymore but this was this was the danger
that these guys did you know I did a
video I think on November 5th of of 2016
the day after Trump got elected we were
building the studio here and I did the
video in the back yard you can find it
and what I kept saying was this is this
is what you guys have created if you
keep doing this you keep calling him
Hitler you keep calling everyone Nazis
and we're all racist it's not what
you're doing to us you fools
what it is is you're painting yourself
in a corner because how are you
one day when you realize that oh my god
maybe that guy isn't Hitler maybe the
economy is doing great maybe he's
helping people live free or
lives maybe he's actually is draining
the swamp and all of this stuff and his
supporters aren't racist and the rest of
it well you've already called them
racist and Hitler you can't walk that
back huh you're not gonna believe this
guys that Hitler guy you know he's
really doing a fine job and that's why
they find themselves going more
increasingly increasingly out of control
because you have to double down and have
to double down because you sold yourself
on a bill of goods that was that was
nonsense from the beginning all right
one more and then we'll jump to a clip
let's see at what point will the
Democratic candidates realized that they
are pandering to the tiniest slivers of
their constituency and they're
completely alienating their largest
voting box I don't know I think it's
what I said before it almost has to this
thing has to get to its logical
conclusion which is a destruction in the
election it is a damn shame but where
are the good Democrats right whether I
let's say there was a good Democratic
Party right now that was a little more
centrist whether that would be a party
for me anymore is this is a separate
issue all together but you know Jordan
Pederson when we were on tour would talk
about this often that regardless if
you're on the left or on the right you
sort of want a healthy opposition
because what's good in a free society is
there's a push in a pull and sometimes
you're gonna kind of lose a little bit
this way sometime you're gonna lose a
little bit this way and what you don't
want is just one ruling ideology all the
time because then that really kind of
get out of control even if even if it's
a good idea in essence right so I think
conservatives right now and I do see
this all the time I find conservatives
all the time saying you know where where
are the good little boats we'd love to
talk to them they well they like me
basically right but it's like but but
you know I can't honestly say I'm part
of the left anymore so it's a little bit
odd I don't know I think this thing has
to just burn out it has to just burn out
and take down a lot of these guys and I
think it will take down Bernie and I'll
take down a bunch of others let's go to
another clip this is oh this was a good
moment for for Andrew yang this is clip
number five
is not the cause of all of our problems
and we were making a mistake when we act
like he is a disease that has been
building up in our communities for years
and decades and it is our job to get to
the harder work of actually curing the
disease most Americans feel like the
political parties have been playing you
lose I lose you lose I lose four years
and you know who's been losing this
entire time we have our communities have
our communities way of life is
disintegrating beneath our feet
that's why Iowa traditional swing state
went to trump by almost 10 points that's
why oh hi oh a traditional swing state
is now so red that I'm told we're not
even going a campaign there so these
communities are seeing their way of life
get blasted into smithereens we've
automated away four million
manufacturing jobs and Counting we're
closing 30% of New Hampshire stores and
malls and Amazon the force behind that
is literally paying zero in taxes these
are the changes that Americans are
seeing and feeling around us every day
and if we get to the hard work of curing
those problems we will not just a feet
Donald Trump in the fall but will
actually be able to move our communities
forward I know we're gonna help so
that's it that's a pretty interesting
statement right there there were a
couple of things that he said that was
interesting first off this this idea
that we just can't always blame Trump
even to the point what he's in essence
what he's saying there cuz he's
obviously not Trump guy is even if I
agree with you on all the Trump stuff
he's saying we can't do it cuz it
doesn't work he also said something sort
of flippantly as an aside which is I
hear we're not gonna campaign in Ohio as
if Ohio is automatically red I mean if
that's if that's the case already then
that's even more reason to think Trump's
gonna win this thing I lands I don't
know if he meant we meaning his campaign
or if he met Democrats in general I
don't know what he meant there but I
think what you see there what you see
there with Andrew Yang and unfortunately
Tulsi Gabbard wasn't on the stage that
the basic bones of that were the right
idea for what a Democratic candidate
should be doing unfortunately he is you
know he's standing all the way to the
left of the screen because he's a fringe
candidate at this point and again I've
had him in the room I think he's a
decent guy for whatever political
disagreements we might have but that's
where they should be headed
you know he did say one thing there in
the fact that you know we go from one
side to the other side but we keep
losing I mean the thing is the economy's
doing really well right now and we're
not going into extra Wars so I don't
know how much more you would want I mean
there's a lot of really good signs right
now and actually just today I
interviewed Richard Grinnell who's the
American ambassador to Germany I think
we're putting it up next week really
really interesting guy and gave me some
really cool insight into the way that we
are actually forging new alliances and
you know when they did that section on
foreign policy about how everybody hates
us now at NATO hates us and we and all
of this and the UN Eights us and blah
blah blah and Rick who's become a good
friend of mine he was telling me how
none of that is true that you know
behind the scenes people are loving that
America is reasserting itself and the
rest of it and that actually countries
are now paying their fair share and they
realized that we mean what we say so I
think in some level yang is a little his
his mark is a little bit off but I think
he's got the general idea of what a good
Democrat should be I was pretty damn
close guys I said that the top 1% make
450 grand according to the Economic
Policy Institute you are in the top 1%
of us earners if you make 421 thousand
nine hundred and twenty-six dollars so
420 grand you're in the top one percent
so again and to say oh it's the fault of
the 1% now would we all love to have 420
grand right yeah ain't given up that
much but would we all love to have that
of course we would but if at 400 went a
grand I assure you you're not pulling
the power the levers of power and and
certainly if you tripled that you're
still not doing it so that's why they've
now moved on to two billionaires all
right let's see Dave this is taken
directly from the DNC 2016 party
platform
what follows is our 2016 party platform
our most progressive platform in our
party's history and a declaration of how
we plan to move America forward
Democrats believe that cooperation is
better than conflict unity is better
than division empowerment is better than
resentment and bridges are better than
walls Dave what grade would give the
Democrats for their ability to maintain
their own standards over the past four
years I mean I'd say Adi basically but
but listen to that statement I mean the
statement itself it just
you that what and I always every time
Bernie tweets I'm always tempted you
just retweet him and just say
meaningless slogan number 462
meaningless slogan five thousand ninety
seven point eight because it all sounds
good but upon any scrutiny it's all
meaningless I mean what does this mean a
declaration of how we'd move America
forward Democrats believe the
cooperation is better than conflict
unity better than division empowerment
better than resentment and bridges are
better than walls I mean that that all
sort of sounds nice word better than
scary word but it doesn't mean anything
it doesn't mean anything sometimes you
need some conflict right so cooperation
is better than conflict not if the other
person is completely insane and you're
gonna have to cooperate with an insane
person you might need some conflict
there so they just say these things that
are just these empty meaningless slogans
free college for everybody where we can
teach you socialism and won't teach you
real math free and of course it's not
really free you know we're gonna forgive
student debt well you know I wanted to
go to Syracuse University back in 1994
when I was going to college long time
ago right and my dad said to me you want
to go to Syracuse University it's a
private school at the time it was
something like 25 grand a year it's um
it's I think now around 60 grand a year
my dad said if you're if you want to go
to a private school well it's time you
figure out how to do it I'm not paying
for it and then my dad said but if you
go to a New York state school a SUNY
school State University of New York
School where we have some excellent
schools there will pay for it and it was
about 9 grand a year and that's what I
chose to do and I went to SUNY
Binghamton which is pretty much the best
New York state school there is and it's
like well if I knew that 25 years later
that Bernie Sanders was gonna pay all my
student debt off well then maybe I would
have done it it also just doesn't make
any sense so you're gonna pay off all
student debt so all the rich kids who go
to super-exclusive colleges you're gonna
pay off their debt too I mean none of it
makes sense and why would you punish all
of the people who did it right right
like we just paid off David's last bit
of college debt why did we do it why did
we do it we did it because it was the
right thing and he had debt but well I
guess we should have waited around for
Bernie to magically pay it off alright
let's go to another clip oh this was
this was really a joy so remember we
killed Iranian general Soleimani who's
been
a mastermind of terrorism all over that
region for many years we killed him
Trump killed him about a month ago
everyone said it was going to be World
War three this is a nightmare this is a
terrible scenario World War three is
apparently over already
World War three ended faster than the
Iowa caucus but here is Budaj edge
talking about mr. soleimani oh sorry
this is number eight one of the people
who prosecuted the Nazi war criminals
after World War two and that's part of
the reason I started because when you
see something really wrong in the United
States you're supposed to stand up
against it and fight against it and
that's what I was doing oh you know what
sorry FS we're we're on the fly here
that was clip number six guys so let's
let's not do that
you do we have no right there we we got
it all right let's throw to number eight
here we go money was a bad actor who was
responsible for the deaths of many
Americans given what you know about
soleimani if your national security team
came to you with an opportunity to
strike would Soleimani have been dead or
would he still be alive under your
presidency in the situation that we saw
with President Trump's decision there is
no evidence that that made our country
safer look I feel very strongly about
the campaign of murder and mayhem that
general Soleimani and his units have
perpetrated it's also the case that if
we learned nothing else from the war in
Iraq
it's that taking out a bad guy is not a
good idea if you do not know what you
were doing there's a lot of nonsense in
that clip so first off he's comparing it
to taking out a bad guy what he means is
taking out Saddam except with Saddam we
toppled a regime that's very different
than taking out a terrorist mastermind
with one strike and by the way as these
people were all screaming about
World War three I mean they were
literally saying this is the beginning
of World War three
not only did Iran basically do nothing
right they shot a couple of rockets they
ended up shooting down our Ukrainian
airliner in their own airspace not only
did they do nothing but we restored
something called deterrence right the
idea is peace through strength you show
other countries that we don't want more
and how do you show them we don't want
it by saying we're gonna occasionally do
some things to rough you up if you if
you start messing around and also
there's sort of this idea that if if you
just let people just kill innocent
people that that somehow is more morally
correct than you doing anything now I'm
not for nation-building I'm not for
toppling regimes you can find videos of
me on The Young Turks when I was still a
lefty saying that we the United States
should have nothing to do in Syria that
maybe we could create a humanitarian
corridor but we should not be going in
there militarily you can find videos
where I was completely against Obama's
kinetic military action remember he'd I
mean no one had even heard that phrase
it sounded like Xbox Kinect something
military something something I was
completely against that Obama toppled
Qaddafi and now Libya we don't talk
about it you know why cuz it's not even
a country anymore in effect nobody knows
what the hell is going on over there
so you know it's a little bit you know
it's it's a Reagan idea you know peace
through strength it's not just a Reagan
idea I mean it's an idea that goes back
hundreds of years actually you know
there's this other idea of course is the
counter which is oh well we'll just be
nice to everybody we'll sit and we'll
talk to everybody but you know the other
guys may not be wanting to sit and talk
so I just don't think we're going to
extra Wars with these people and
sometimes you take out somebody and it
doesn't mean that all hell is gonna
break loose and I think that's what what
we've seen so far okay let's see most
democratic candidates have moved
substantially towards socialism will the
ones resisting get a taste of the
canceled culture that other people other
public figures such as such as yourself
has experienced yeah yeah I think so you
know I had Adam Carolla in here what was
that about six weeks ago something like
that and what one of the things he
talked about how is he's always able to
figure out which Hollywood celebrities
are conservatives because it's the ones
that just never say anything right so if
you're a
in Hollywood you're a Democrat you know
tomorrow's the Oscars right here in this
town I was invited to the Elton John
Oscar party but I'm not going if you if
you are a lefty or a Democrat or
whatever it is a socialist or whatever
that whole thing is at this point if
you're one of them you could say
whatever you want you go up at the
awards show you lecture half the country
you tell everybody how racist they all
are and then you're like come to my
movies please and you know there's this
other group of people that just never
say anything and I think that Corolla is
right not only are they conservatives
which would make sense actually if
secretly in this town there were a lot
of conservatives because la is a town
that's based in really in one industry
Hollywood you're right and or let's say
now it's beyond Hollywood because now
there's a lot of this sort of things so
it's not just Hollywood traditional
moviemaking but it's a lot of people
that come here to fulfill their dreams
and bust their asses to do something and
work all sorts of awful jobs to do it
and want to be creative and free and all
of those things so actually that that's
a lot of what the individual is all
about and that's not a staple of what
modern leftism is it's a staple of what
traditional conservatism is so it's a
really weird situation so I think
there's a ton of Hollywood celebrities I
think there's a ton of look I can eat
I'll even say this I haven't said this
publicly yeah but I've been thinking
about a lot think about sort of my crew
whoever you may think that is in the in
the YouTube game notice that very few
except for except for I would say
Shapiro really talked about impeachment
that much I think that tells you a
little something right like that tells
you something just read between the
lines of what I'm trying to tell you and
maybe I'll talk about it more over the
next couple weeks but like if you didn't
say anything about impeachment it was
partly because you were afraid that the
left base was gonna come eat you and if
you didn't say anything it was probably
because you weren't for impeachment so
there this thing and that's just that
pressure machine can kind of get to
everybody it's it's definitely worrisome
for sure do you see the rise of
anti-establishment candidates becoming
the new norm in politics well that's
interesting I mean it's definitely gonna
be a trend for now right it's gotta be a
trend for now because Biden is the
establishment guy right now and it's
just not working I think there was a
version
of an establishment person I don't know
who it is but it was not supposed to be
Biden maybe what maybe what Obama needed
to do realizing that this insurrection
which he sort of fermented was coming
Biden needed to start grooming some
stronger younger Democrat but because he
didn't do it or maybe maybe he truly
didn't see this coming
it was it left them sort of naked so
Biden's the establishment guy so the
anti-establishment guy Bernie is the one
that seems to have the energy right
Elizabeth Warren's not really
anti-establishment because she's just
she's a Harvard like she comes from the
Machine Pete is a is a Rhodes Scholar
guy he's not you know yang I would say
is more of an anti-establishment guy
going you know he's a exactly actually
accomplish things in the private sector
that's a big no-no if you're a modern
Democrat so yeah I do think outsiders
are going to are going to be the new
thing with the Democrats for a while and
then you know it'll be interesting to
see what happens post Trump on the
Republican so I assume Trump is gonna
win again and then the new conservatives
after Trump do they run as establishment
people going Oh see the guy before us
Trump gave us eight good years let's say
so now we want to continue that or does
something go completely haywire and then
they have to go at the establishment but
I think of you constantly your
anti-establishment that's not healthy
for the long-term survival of the
country because in essence you're always
trying to tear everything down and by
the way that's why Klobuchar I thought
actually made some sense tonight as I
said earlier because she it's very clear
she talks about things like oh we can't
always get everything we want we have to
reach across the aisle not everybody
before us was the old racist bastard
these are these are sensible positions
all right let's go to another video clip
oh this is number four we're gonna go to
Klobuchar praising Doug Jones and
Romney's courage in the moment meeting
the moment we had a moment the last few
weeks mayor and that moment was these
impeachment hearings and there was a lot
of courage that you saw from only a few
people there was courage from Doug Jones
our friend of Alabama who took that
tough call
[Applause]
there was courage from Mitt Romney who
took a very very difficult read today
about Lieutenant Colonel Benjamin being
escorted out of the White House what he
took took her it but what you said Pete
as you were campaigning through Iowa and
three of us were jurors in that
impeachment hearing you said it was
exhausting to watch and that you wanted
to turn the channel and watch cartoons
it is easy to go after Washington
because that's a popular thing to do it
is much harder as I see senator Shaheen
in the front row such a leader it is
much harder to lead and much harder to
take those difficult positions because I
think that's going after every single
thing that people do because it's
popular to say and makes you look like a
cool new comer I just I don't think
that's what people want right now we
have a newcomer in the White House and
look where it got us
I think having some experience all right
I've been very fair to Klobuchar but I
do want to say in defense of cartoons
when I've been doing cardio lately I've
been watching remember the Clone Wars
series not the not the digital one
remember Cartoon Network did a series of
shorts it all added up to about two
hours that take place between episodes
two and three so between attack of the
clones and Revenge of the Sith and it
ends in a really cool way I don't want
to blow a guy maybe I'll blow a little
sign because it's been out for ten years
but if you're ever wondering why general
grievous coughs in Revenge of the Sith
they show it to you you find out in the
last five minutes of the Clone Wars
cartoon so let's not make this let's not
put down people who watch cartoons miss
clova char that aside this thing about
bravery and the way all the Democrats
all the Democrats who said Romney was a
racist and Romney hated women and he had
binders full of women and he's an evil
capitalist and all this stuff
now Romney does what they want and now
he's brave and the media is now treating
him like a hero this is what
conservatives and right-leaning people
are always fighting right so it's like
Romney's realizing at this point he's
become powerless nobody really likes him
he somehow got into the Senate just on
his name and it's like oh and he
obviously hates Trump and Trump hates
him but if you think it makes sense that
he was the one
Republican to vote against Trump here
and that it wasn't sort of personal I
mean that's probably pretty crazy but
then the media starts treating him like
he's like he's this wonderful wonderful
thing the same guy that they were saying
as a misogynist and a racist four years
ago so or eight years ago so it's uh you
know that's a little bit disingenuous
you're not just someone isn't just brave
because they do what they want they're
brave because they actually stand for
their convictions now maybe she thinks
these people are standing for their
convictions but I I don't suspect it and
the way the media treated him certainly
wasn't because the media knows nothing
about standing for their convictions
alright let's go to another question and
then we'll go to the videotape let's see
how Blair was warned every time she
spoke I was like whoa I forgot she was
there yeah she's done
I'm telling you call it tonight Warren's
done her base what if you were if you
like Warren why wouldn't you love Bernie
right and Warren just she's the worst
sort of intersectional know-nothing
know-it-all that there possibly is did
you see her thing this week she was
gonna make sure that she would hire a
young trans person so that that young
trans person could hire other non-binary
people or her cabin it's gonna be half
non-binary and half female I did a thing
on Tucker about this like a week ago
it's all just intersectional stupidity
with her and it's just the and and it's
also like ladies smile show a human and
by the way even funnier than any of this
she says all her WH words like white
white she says it like whip like Cool
Whip like Stewie from Family Guy pull up
the Stewie Family Guy Cool Whip thing
and then listen to her pronounce a WH
okay let's go to another clip ah boo de
jedge not happy with our supreme court
let's go to clip number ten he's gonna
change it for you you have signaled that
you'd be open to the idea of expanding
the Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
accepted leaving the court as it is
saying quote nine seems to be a good
number in fact she said if the number of
justices is increased quote it would
make the court appear partisan it would
be one side saying when we're in power
we're going to enlarge the number of
judges to have more people who will vote
the way we want them to is Justice
Ginsburg wrong well
if all we did was change the number of
Justices then I agree with her that that
could be the consequence what I've
called for is not only reforming the
number of justices on the bench but
structural reforms so that some of the
justices are not appointed through a
partisan process we cannot allow the
Supreme Court to continue to become one
more political battlefield as we are
seeing today and the time has come for
us to think bigger
not just reforming the makeup of the
court as America by the way has done
several times in our history but also
remember that the founders gave us the
power to amend the Constitution for a
reason and we shouldn't be afraid to use
it
it's not something you do lightly or
quickly but when it comes to something
like citizens united which holds that
corporations have the same political
soul as people and that's spending money
to influence an election is the same
thing as writing an op-ed to your local
paper we need a constitutional amendment
to clear that up and protect our
democracy Mayor Budaj thank you you know
I don't have any major problems with the
Citizens United thing and I and I hear
from right-leaning people all the time
that you just have to let people you
know put as much money that that's money
is speech you can if you have money you
can do whatever you want I think there's
an interesting argument there I don't
want to talk about that specifically at
the moment although I'll do maybe I'll
do a show on the ruling and and some of
the fallout I think what's more
worrisome is the way they talk about the
fact that they want to change so many of
the fundamental ways we have governed
ourselves right so they want to
potentially change or get rid of the
electoral college change the amount of
Supreme Court seats
change voting rules all of these things
and it's like this has worked really
well for a long time we can do little
movements on the side that's all we
should ever really be doing in America
because it's still pretty damn good here
so I would I also it's not the job of
the President to do that by the way he
said what I've called for well it's not
the job of the President to call for
changing what another branch of
government is supposed to do he is the
president that is the head of the
executive branch he's supposed to sign
laws into being he's not supposed to
create laws that's supposed to be the
legislative branch
Congress in the Senate and they don't do
that very well or very often anymore and
then those other guys the judicial
branch they're supposed to make sure
they're actually actually legal then we
have checks and balances to make sure
the whole thing kind of works it is not
the job of the president to decide how
another branch of government should or
should not be changed so yeah he's a
little confused on that one
let's see now I'm watching Tarzan on
prime and to be honest it's an easier
story to believe that the ones that the
ones the candidates are trying to sell
me and margot robbie is better to look
at than Bernie I'm a little confusing
but the beginning men but I feel like
there's something in there that is a
point did I miss something all right
let's see are leftists winning the long
game with strategies to secure perpetual
power I mean look that's what they want
that's what they want right they want
power they want power I mean think about
it this way so right now let's say let's
say you're Bette Midler who's having a
nervous breakdown or you were Carl Ron
well Carl Reiner - but Rob Reiner you're
any of the litany of celebrities who all
day long tailed Trump - you know go go
you know if I say the F word they tell
me that these videos get D monetized so
I'm not gonna say it but you know that
I'm okay Seng but they tell Trump to go
F himself all the time and the second
Trump tweets a million people say you're
gonna rot in hell you're gonna die
you're evil all these things no no it's
not Minority Report nobody's coming and
knocking on their doors and taking them
out for thoughtcrime right nothing's
happening to these people try to take it
the other way now let's say we're like
ten years from now now aoc is president
she's you know or someone of her ilk is
president right Bernie's president then
they and then it becomes more extreme
after because the left always goes to
its further and further extremes right
do you think people on the right the
people that they call Nazis that they're
always telling you how we have to stop
their free speech and ban them from
platforms and all the other stuff do you
think that if they're out there telling
president aoc god forbid to go after
sell for the rest of it do you think
that they wouldn't love to use state
power to silence these people and
silence journalists because I think they
would I actually do think they would
because they believe state power is
theirs to wield so you may hate Trump
but no one's being jailed there are no
journalists being jailed right now you
can say whatever you want about Trump
and it's and it's okay there's our
freaking cottage cottage industry of
people that do it so yeah these people
want power and I don't think there's
much that will stop them the only thing
that will stop them is is this thing
getting to its logical conclusion and
getting and getting crushed much like
what happened with the Labour Party in
the UK oh here's a good one speaking of
socialism this is clip number two nobody
really wanted to denounce socialism they
just asked is anyone else on the stage
concerned about having a Democratic
Socialist at the top of the Democratic
ticket yeah it's funny it's funny I
guess that was funny yeah if this is
what you guys want I mean that was a
moment you know you saw yang really in
the corner there why didn't he just put
his hand up and say guys I'm different
than you I I don't think the government
should absolutely do everything I do we
think we have to think about these
things in a new way I don't consider
myself a socialist I'd like you bi but I
don't think that the government should
run everything and you bi should replace
existing programs and it would function
better or whatever it is that he would
have said but they're all sort of afraid
of each other they're actually afraid to
say they're not socialist because that's
what the base which I it's always hard
to tell what the Democratic base is
anymore because if you look on Twitter
it's just a bunch of genderless queer
anime frog avatars or not frogs it's the
unicorns usually or something who always
are the worst people online you know I
do find that to be really funny I'm sure
you guys have seen this to the Bernie
people especially they all are he/him
she her it day whatever it is and
they're there unicorns and they're
always brightly coloured sprites and
that sort of thing or almost all
anonymous and their names look all
exactly the same they ever rose in their
picture they're always all absolutely
awful
like they're just terrible terrible
people I just block and viewed all of
them it doesn't matter but like I see
young people debating people
interestingly having having good
conversation online
ability to agree to disagree you know I
see it from some of the other candidates
I've never seen anyone defend Biden
online but that they'd just be me who
knows
okay we'll do a couple more questions
and then maybe we'll throw to one or two
more clips and then I think we're gonna
wrap by the way guys if you are playing
along at home for now on when I do these
live streams and I'm gonna do more with
guests after these things that I think
will do something for Super Tuesday and
we may do some on location oh and by the
way in about two weeks I will be
announcing the dumper in this book tour
we officially got all the dates I think
on the 24th I believe on the 24th it's
gonna be there'll be a private
announcement for subscribers and then I
think around the 28th will start doing
some presale stuff but the tour begins
on April 28th in New York City I can
tell you that the hometown New York and
my book comes out on April 28 if you
haven't bought the book and you want to
check it out it is don't burn this book
calm you can buy it right now we've sold
a ton so I'm pretty sure we'll be a New
York Times best seller which is sort of
ironic because at some level the whole
book is about destroying New York Times
and those ridiculous institutions but it
still would be nice to be on the list
and and yeah so I look forward to
getting out to all over America and
talking to you guys and then so we're
gonna do like a two-month American tour
and then it looks like we'll do some
stuff up in Canada and then I think in
June we'll probably be in the UK and
then maybe a little bit of a Western
Europe thing in July and then you know I
dip out for August and then we'll we'll
go from there
oh by the way I'll also have some big
announcement announcements for locals
com coming soon we've started to build
something really really cool I've been
spending a lot of my time just trying to
raise funds for the next round so that
we can grow this thing properly and
scale it properly if you haven't just
checked out the Reuben report community
just go to Reuben report calm create an
account just start looking around you
don't have to pay anything to get in if
you want to interact and the rest of it
you can pay as little or as much as you
want to do that and as I said before
there's an iOS app and an Android app
just search Reuben report and either one
of those in either one of those stores
well this will be a good one to be the
last question
so I'll take one more video and then
we'll do one more question how about oh
this is clip number three when they were
talking about medicare-for-all let's do
that we are spending twice as much per
capita on health care as do the people
of any other country
maybe it has something to do with the
fact that the healthcare industry last
year made a hundred billion dollars in
profit maybe it has something to do with
the fact that we are wasting five
hundred billion dollars a year trying to
administer thousands and thousands of
different plants what Medicare for all
will do is save the average American
substantial sums of money substantial be
much less expensive than your plan and
we will expand Medicare to include
dental class eyeglasses hearing aids and
home health care as well
what Bernie's not telling you there is
that when the government takes over
everything that then there's no
competition so then the quality of
service gets lowered and then you have
to wait on longer lines to get stuff and
then it we're gonna become a problem and
then the whole thing starts collapsing
on itself and next thing you know you're
eating brains in the back of an alley
because you're hungry because also
there's bread lines I mean the tone with
this guy it's like Jesus Christ is any I
mean how do you listen to this first off
okay are there problems with our health
care system of course there are is there
a perfect health service system of
course there isn't
but what I always think is interesting
as they're always talking about how
horrible our health care system is is
they're really all just throwing
Obamacare on the bus right like that was
his signature thing that was the thing
Obama was supposed to ride that the
horse out on and go yeah how I gave you
Obamacare well it must have been pretty
freakin horrible I suppose so Biden what
we didn't show there was it was either
right before right effort but Biden
basically is like Bernie you have no
idea how you're gonna pay for and you
have no idea how much it's gonna cost
and by the way Bernie he admitted that
on an interview a few days ago he has no
idea what it's gonna cost but he doesn't
care he doesn't care but what he doesn't
understand also is just basic
fundamental economic concepts I would
welcome you to watch any interview that
anyone's ever done or any lecture by
Thomas ol watch the interview I did with
him you need competition Bernie wants
Medicare for all so there won't even be
private insurance what right does he
have to tell you that even if the
government gave everybody a public
health insurance that you have no right
to private health insurance
and you know damn well that he's gonna
be able to next time he has a heart
attack get pretty good coverage even
under his system he won't have to wait
in line the way you will have to so it's
all sort of silly nonsense and all right
I'm gonna take one more question this is
a good one and I've been getting in a
lot will you vote for Trump it actually
says are you voting for Trump so are you
voting for Trump so look here's where
I'm at right now I think you know how I
feel about these people this this is
just an absolute disaster I believe that
we need a decent Democratic Party I
don't think that is this party I think
this party has to go in the way that it
has to go the way of the dodo bird
basically and then we can see what
happens after that I think Trump
basically has done a good job I think
that F despite impeachment despite three
years of Russia you know I was watching
I was watching Maddow a couple days ago
and I never watch it but I had happened
to have the MSNBC on I haven't watched
MSNBC in years you know I see little
clips on Twitter's but I haven't I
haven't actually put the channel on but
but when Larry King was here for State
of the Union he wanted to watch MSNBC so
I had the channel on next time I turned
on the TV and I flicked on a Maddow and
it's like the look of depression in her
face right now knowing that she pushed
Russia for three years she pushed the
impeachment they're gonna try for
another impeachment and when Trump gets
reelected they'll try for another and
they're just gonna destroy everything
that was good so where are the JFK's
that was a good Democrat or the senator
when I was growing up from New York
Daniel Patrick Moynihan who I had the
pleasure of meeting once or Mayor Ed
Koch who was a great man who I also
interviewed many many years ago in my
old Sirius XM show where are these guys
I don't know where there are so I'm not
gonna sit here right this second and
tell you that I'm voting for Trump but I
see no reason at this point I see no
reason not to vote for Trump but I will
promise you this for sure so last time
you may remember that in August before
the election
I basically endorsed whatever you want
to call it Gary Johnson because my hope
was you know I didn't like Trump I
didn't like Hillary but what I really
wanted was some of the good ideas of
libertarianism and limited government to
get out there and I thought well let's
just get that Gary Johnson in one debate
and I knew that he wasn't if he got in
one he would
do well he wasn't a particularly good
debater he would always forget what he
was saying he didn't know where Aleppo
was he couldn't name one foreign leader
he respected there were a lot of
problems with this guy right he didn't
even wish he wanted to force the Baker
to bake the gay wedding cake like that's
so antithetical to libertarian thinking
that it's beyond imagination he was very
very flawed I had him on the show
totally a nice guy I'd love to smoke a
joint with him right but that's not I
sorry what I want to have a president
but my hope was if I support this guy I
could sort of live with myself and go
forward then flash-forward - to November
of last year or sorry the last election
cycle and David and I moved into this
house so we had to drive back to a close
to our old house for the polling station
and we're we're driving it's about a
20-minute drive and the whole Drive I'm
going I don't know what I'm gonna do
this is what I do for a living but I
don't know what I'm gonna do like I
don't know if I'm voting for Hillary or
Trump right now I don't know what to do
anyway we used to live in West Hollywood
which is the gayest place in the history
of the world okay it's gayer than Oz
they have rainbow crosswalks it's gay
gay gay I get on line in West Hollywood
at the polling place and I'm literally
standing behind RuPaul I thought I will
not forget this I don't know what I'm
gonna do right now so there's RuPaul I
go into the booth and David gave me a
little pep talk right before we started
and basically what he said was look
we're in California you can vote for
Gary Johnson here because it won't it
won't matter it won't matter your vote
won't matter because we know Hillary is
gonna win in a landslide and that's what
I did so my promise to you this time is
I will not vote third party this time I
will I will make a clear distinction and
I will gladly and proudly tell you who
I'm gonna vote for beforehand I will not
take that third party option I don't
think I don't think it would be right
for me to do
and that's sort of where I'm at with
things anyway I thank you guys for
watching we got a ton of good stuff
going on as I said we're building a
seriously awesome community if you guys
haven't joined if you're sick of the
Twitter trolls and the fighting on
YouTube and the rest of it if you join a
Rubin report com
we've got video and audio and an awesome
community of cool people there are no
trolls and BOTS because you've got to
pay a couple bucks to get in and so that
means the trolls either have to pay me
or I just boot them but if I boot them
they're not being deep platformed
because they can still be in anyone
elses local so Rueben report.com and our
community is the first project of locals
calm we've on-boarded Bridgette Fred
Izzie and Michael malice we got a bunch
of people come in some big names on the
way my book don't burn this book
thinking for your free thing thinking
for yourself in an age of unreason man
that whiskey is coming out on April 28th
so I'm excited about that we got the
book tour and a bunch of other stuff so
thank you very much and I guess we'll
keep doing these i mean they're they're
killing me I mean did anyone enjoy this
thing I hope you enjoyed this but I mean
that thing Jesus Christ alright that's
it